hi I'm Evan Carmichael and welcome to
another edition of modeling the masters
today we're going to look at how the son
of immigrant laborers went against his
parents dreams of him becoming a
preacher and built one of the most
successful companies in the food
production business this is the story of
Henry Heinz in the top three lessons
that you can learn from his success
Henry John Heinz was an American
businessman founded the HJ Heinz Company
he was the first of eight children born
the German immigrant parents who wanted
him to become a preacher Heinz Walker
had other plans his passion was helping
his mother bottle and sell the pickles
she grew in their yard and he saw his
future in food production by the time he
was just nine years old Heinz was
growing grindy and bottling and selling
his own brand with horseradish sauce at
10:00 punch was given 3/4 of an acre of
land to tent his own garden a 12 he
graduated three and a half acres of land
and is using a horse and cart to make
his deliveries to grocery stores when
the time can reach 17 years old Heinz
was making twenty four hundred dollars a
year from his brother's close to sixty
thousand and today's dollars
Heinz eventually expanded his business
by focusing on making new product lines
include pickles and ketchup
I'm still on as president of the company
he founded until his death at age 74 at
that time the HJ Heinz Company had more
than 25 food processing plants 40,000
acres of land under cultivation and over
6,500 employees by following his passion
and by working hard Heinz was eventually
able to make his parents proud and
dominate his industry to help you
dominate your industry
here are three action items that you can
learn from Henry hi
action I am number one create a catchy
slogan whatever industry you're in you
probably have many competitors how can
you stand out from everyone else a great
way to cut through the clutter is to
create a catchy slogan that highlights
what you're really good at Hines was
looking for a slogan while riding on a
streetcar in New York one day in 1896 he
then saw an advertisement for a shoe
store that red 21 styles putting the
hinds I said to myself
we don't have styles of products but we
do have varieties of models handed up
how many we had accounted well beyond 57
but 57 kept coming back to my mind 7-7
there are so many illustrations of the
psychological influence of that figure
and its alluring significance to people
of all ages and races at 58 varieties or
59 varieties didn't appeal to me as
being equally strong with that Hines
immediately jumped off the streetcar
went down to the print shop and drafted
up a card with the new 57 variety slogan
reflecting back Hines acknowledged I
myself did not realize how highly
successful slogan it was going to be
action item number two be unique with
your promotions another great way to cut
through the clutter and have potential
customers pay attention to you is to be
unique with your promotional campaigns
no tactic was too flashy oh gallery for
Heinz he wanted his products to stand
out in shine literally in 1900 Heinz
decided to erect the first ever electric
sign in New York City on the corner of
Fifth Avenue and 23rd Street in
Manhattan standing six stories tall the
sign was a large electrical it pickle
the for the Heinz name and his 57
varieties slogan in the display room
below the sign Heinz employees could be
seen packing miniature pickles into
bottles the science of 1200 lightbulbs
to build and cost the company some $90
every night but for Heinz it was all
worth it four years is Electric pickle
and fresh shoppers along the famous New
York Strip and served as invaluable
advertising
Hinds was a master promoter and was even
responsible for Pok pioneering one of
the major trends in the industry
obsesses quality freshness and
cleanliness Hinds invented the concept
of the factory tour anyone who is
interested in seeing how high is
produced and packaged his products was
now allowed to witness the product
firsthand he was confident in his
operations and believed opening up for
the public would help build confidence
and trust in his company the move
sparked an outburst of positive
publicity not to mention a wave of
copycats action item number three have a
quality product and be proud of it most
of the famous entrepreneurs achieve
success not because they were trying to
make a lot of money but because they
created a product or service that was
good quality and that they were proud to
make and promote Heinz was very proud of
all of his products in addition to
allowing the public access to his
factories he also opened up his products
with them literally
he was one of the first to ever packages
products in clear glass bottles Heinz's
competitors would often use filler
ingredients to pump up the volume of the
products and then conceal the fact by
using opaque color containers Heinz
wanted his customers to see exactly what
they were buying he was proud of his
products quality and other transparent
bottles to ensure customers they were
getting their money's worth
- biographer Robert C Albert's claimed
that Heinz had hit one of the most
important and shaping business ideas of
his time that a pure article of superior
quality could find a ready market
through its intrinsic value so long as
it was packaged and promoted properly
so remember create a catchy slogan be
unique with your promotions and have a
quality product and be proud of it to
finish up this video I wanted to share
one of my favorite true stories about
Henry Heinz and some of his best quotes
in the banking panic of 1875 a young
Heinz found himself overextended and
bankrupt he had tried unsuccessfully to
turn for help to the grocers he had been
supplying with produce over the past few
years they however turned their backs on
him too he couldn't even get enough
credit to feed his family with that
Heinz decided that he would never again
be placed in a situation where he had to
depend on others to survive he made a
decision to be successful and never
looked back
thank you for joining me for another
edition of modeling the masters if you
enjoyed please give the video a thumbs
up below I'd also love to hear your
feedback if you want to leave a comment
and stay tuned for the next episode
you